well i know why you're happy today uh
joe biden is up by eight
uh
to pee what did you think as for our
as for our covet infected uh president
uh tonight he's going to undergo a
medical exam
really this is happening on fox news uh
in a
very special episode of dirty jobs
now now the
the doctor is in new york and trump's in
the white house
i'm not sure how this is really an exam
but i hope it involves trump sticking
his own finger up his ass that's all i
have to say
but uh you know what
i've always been conservative about
saying about trump oh we got him now but
i'm telling you this
getting covert thing not good for him
the way he handled it i think the final
blow is that you know what
he he we see that he gets treatment we
would never get he's
he's out there every day bragging about
oh i beat it yeah with a team of doctors
and experimental drugs you know when
when trump gets sick he goes to walter
reed the average american goes to dwayne
reed
yeah he's on an experimental antibody
cocktail that was tested on hamsters
it's a little risky but they say as of
tonight the president is doing fine
and resting comfortably near his wheel
you know and the other thing is that
he's literally infected
others i mean this [ __ ] country is so
[ __ ] dense that they only could get
it through their head he's a bad guy
when he personally is killing other
people
personally this
usa today says he and his entourage
have infected or exposed at least 6 000
people in
five states beating the old record set
by motley crue
i mean things are so upside
things are so upside down in this
country today stormy daniels called him
a super spreader
wow
so far now we're keeping count 34 people
34 connected to the white house
have become infected when the helicopter
lands on the lawn now they play the
theme from mash
is that a sign that things are
i mean and in the white house they're
going nuts they're freaking out they've
got workers
wiping down every inanimate object desks
computers wilbur ross
and oh today uh jared kushner was
wearing a plastic mask
oh no that was his face
but uh uh melania says she is feeling
stronger although she said this year
might be the year
christmas has to go [ __ ] itself
you saw that story not many people okay
that doesn't matter
well the people who work in the white
house yeah they are going nuts because
of this because trump's returning there
sooner than he should have
he's still infectious he's still
endangering the staff and the staff of
course has not said anything about this
publicly
but privately oh i would love to be a
fly on mike pence's face
to hear what they are saying
did you watch that debate i have nothing
to say about it it was boring i'm voting
for biden next
i mean like did it change anything now i
mean and the debate commission now
says the the next presidential debate uh
could only happen remotely because
trump is infected and trump has canceled
this he said no he doesn't want to do
debate that way
he said his infectious personality
just doesn't come across on zoom
and amid all this get this remember ken
bone from the last election the guy with
the red sweater the ultimate
independent voter we look at to decide
things in this country he finally has
made his decision
after looking at trump for almost four
years and joe biden
ken bone's going to vote for the
libertarian candidate joe
jorgensen really ken bone yes that's ken
bone's decision and tonight to celebrate
his vote he's going out to a chinese
restaurant and ordering hamburger
you